it shows the level of threat they have
been causing the IDF and Israel as a
whole and I saw mammed ja's name then I
was like damn yes my name wasn't there
that means I haven't been doing
enough brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing de that you want to do but
we turn it into a moneymaking machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this walk this building and
every single time the money generated
from that W that building is going to go
to our Palestinian brothers and sisters
for the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150
years and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subh bless and preserve you
guys brother and sisters and dear
friends recently a picture was circulate
circulating on the internet and on X
previously known as Twitter of the names
that were written down on these um bombs
that are using to kill innocent men
women and children babies Todds yes they
were kids yes and usually they were
writing the names of themselves now
these individuals as you guys know who
have no shame idea has absolutely
exposed their and I'll be honest I'm a
bit jealous why because the people that
are on there it shows the level of
threat they have been causing the idea
in Israel as a whole and I saw Mam's
name then I was like damn yes my name
was in there that means I haven't been
doing enough and mamab was been
intellectually dropping these
intellectual bombs on them left right
center especially especially on the
Unholy shimoli yes and I have no doubt
that his son the war criminal terrorist
his real son yes his son is a terrorist
the war war criminal I'm very sure
because unho has been crying about hijab
since that debate happened the guy
hasn't let go of hijab name he's been
talking about him over and over and over
again my gosh the damage the humiliation
that he suffered that day he will
remember for the last from till the day
he will die with us Muslims the moment
we die yes we take the Shah it looks
like for Unholy shimi his last words
before he dies is going to be Muhammad
hijab yes he's been so hurt that I
believe he got his son to write these
names down and write Muhammad's name
down this only shows let me tell you
something it's an honor it's a badge of
honor to show that your enemies who
Target only civilians for that matter
who only target civilians babies kids
innocent people and they write your name
on that it shows how hurt they are and
how Shameless they are and how arrogant
and racist they are the zionists we're
talking about so brothers and sisters
Muhammed hijab you should be proud of
yourself that
they could do nothing but just write
your name because they cannot harm you
and not only that this could even be
seen as a threat this could also
insinuate the harming of Muhammad and
individuals on that list on these bombs
that their names written on so I'm going
to end this video on what brothers and
sisters the idea of Israel as a force
yes as this Mass this state this
oppressing state has bought ads on our
channel to change the narrative it's not
working it will never work not only that
it has come to this I'm going to end
with Muhammad hiab's words a message to
all the coward IDF soldiers you cowards
I'm happy the idea for knows who I am
the difference between my intellectual
missile and theirs is mine land where it
matters deep in the troubled psyches of
the enemies of the oppressed let me
prove their cowardice I hereby challenge
anyone in the IDF to a one to1 legal
fight in the UK you have 12 hours to
respond and no you cannot fight my child
as a replacement very well said and put
them in in their place brothers and
sisters they are scared and they are
shook why because they know the whole
world has woken up it's not like before
the Zionist scums of this
Earth should know we are on their necks
intellectually and legally in every
aspect we will not let go and the blood
of the children the Palestinian kids you
will inshallah pay for
it you guys are war criminals and you
should be charged that's all I have to
say brothers and sisters inshallah till
next
time we are happy to see that the
enemies these individuals these baby
killers are shaking in their boots till
next
time